[موسيقى]
صممت هذه الدبابه لتكون مدرعه قتالا
متوسطه لكنها عملت في صفوف القوات
السوفيتيه بدءا من عام 1940 على انها
دبابه قتال رئيسيه تميز الدبابه تي 34
بمقدمه منحدره بزاويه تصل الى 60 درجه هذا
الامر منح حمايه من عدد من المدافع
المضاده للدروع في هذا الوقت كما صلحت
الدبابه ايضا بمدفع من عيار
76.2 مليم هذا الامر استطاع ومكانها من
اختراق تدريج معظم الدبابات الالمانيه في
المرحله الاولى من الحرب العالميه الثانيه
[موسيقى]
كانت احدى ابرز نقاط قوه هذه الدبابه هي
سرعتها والتي بلغت 53 كيلو مترا في الساعه
وكذلك ايضا تصميمه التي اعطاها القدره على
المناوره على ارض المعركه وقطع مسافه
طويله
[موسيقى]
ابرزها هو افتقار البرج لمنظومه رؤيه تتي
حول الطاقم ادراك ما يجري حوله من جميع
جوانب الدبابه اضافه الى افتقارها لمنظار
تصويب دقيق بعيد المدى هذه الامور جعلتها
صاحبه الرقم الاعلى للدبابات التي تم
تدميرها خلال الحرب العالميه الثانيه هذه
العيوب تم علاجها لاحقا تم تحديث برج
الدبابه في عام
1944 وتوسيعه كذلك تم تحسين منظومه الرؤيا
والادراك للمحيط كما انه تم تغيير مدفعها
ليكون اقوى